la dernière fois que vous avez vu
françois legault dans une conférence de
presse sur la coved c'était le 8 février
il y a 6 mois aujourd'hui je répondrai
pas à d'autres questions
sur des sujets à haut que ce qui
concerne la santé publique sa visibilité
ici ne désavantage pas ses adversaires à
la veille de la campagne électorale juge
son équipe au contraire sa présence est
nécessaire après avoir entendu plusieurs
commentaires du genre je le mets trois
doses en ce moment puis je réponds
chercher d'autres j'ai déjà mes 2 puis
s'arrête assez le premier ministre veut
les convaincre d'aller chercher leur
quatrième dose dès la semaine prochaine
protéger les gens
priorité aux 60 ans et plus à partir du
22 ou une semaine plus tard tous les
adultes pourront l'obtenir juste à temps
pour la rentrée scolaire françois
legault veut aussi régler la question de
la vaccination massive avant son
marathon électoral est ce que vous
craignez pas que le gouvernement prenne
pas les décisions importantes qui doit
frange on regarde la queue vite parce
qu'on va être en campagne en coop qui
veut pas de déplaire non seulement en
pro je pense que monsieur legault a
toujours priorisé monsieur dubé autres
je priorise la santé des québécois
les députés caquistes insiste sur
l'indépendance de la santé publique
toutes les recommandations seront suivis
quitte à perdre des points de popularité
on a vu que le gouvernement a été
capable aussi d'annoncer des réparations
et hippolyte la fontaine avant les
élections donc ça s'appelle une
transparence mais pour l'instant il
rappelle qu' aucune restriction
sanitaire n'est envisagée avant de se
rendre jusque-là québec va d'abord
ouvrir les grands centres de vaccination
comme le stade olympique
il se préparer à vacciner 300 mille
personnes par semaine pendant à peu près
150 cliniques de vaccination qui sont
mises en place le qui sont en train de
tout est finalisé ceux qui n'ont pas
contracté l'aco vide ou reçu de vaccin
depuis au moins cinq mois devrait
sérieusement envisager la dose de rappel
selon cet expert le virus qui mute
beaucoup et qui arrivent à contourner
efficacement la réponse immunitaire
françois legault veut affaiblir la
huitième vague que la santé publique
voit venir cet automne celle qui
pourrait devenir son adversaire si comme
premier ministre sortant et la gère mal
alors qu'il est en campagne électorale
comme chef de la caq
ici véronique prince radio canada québec